this video i will be mentioning two
facts which aim to
expose the objectives of the zionist
racist authorities of this state the
corrupt state of israel
which will have the net effect
it will have the net effect of showing
the manipulative nature okay
exposing the manipulative nature
of those individuals who are ruling
elites
in israel and even those before them
before
israel became even a state
but before i do so i just want to say a
word of car on current events
what we're seeing today ladies and
gentlemen
in east jerusalem
is merely a continuation it
is merely a continuation of a system or
an objective
that zionists had from the inception of
israel and even before them
of a process of ethnic cleansing
which has been exposed in historical
works
through things like planned dalit and
i've spoken before about the work that
ilan pape has done and others on
exposing this a norman finkelstein or
exposing this
because the fact of the matter is this
the zionists have been open
candid about their racial preferences
and the fact that they do believe in
racial inequality in terms of
privileging
one set of people ethnic people over
another
this is very clear in the in their works
and in their statements
aya king one the mayor of east jerusalem
has spoken just recently about this
stating quote something to the effect of
and i'm paraphrasing
that the the the the the evictions in
uh part of a broader policy of
installing layers he says installing
layers of jewish people
in the area snope in secret
and that is why anyone anyone
who endorses or acts as an apologist
for the state the corrupt state of
israel and their actions
should be questioned or even accused of
being a racist
in much the same way as someone would be
had they been a supporter of the
apartheid state of south africa
there's practically no difference
between the two sets of policies
so that is a word on current events the
two points i wanted to make in this
video
number one did you know
did you know that the ergun which was a
paramilitary group
which was responsible for killing
civilians directly
okay killing civilians directly and the
most famous terrorist attack was the one
in king david
hotel in 1946 where over 90 people were
killed civilians
british civilians palestinian civilians
were killed
that those individuals who then became
part of the framework by the way of the
lucid party that we see today
those individuals
that those individuals actually had
deals with hitler
and the nazis and this is something
which is not
a conspiracy this is not conspiratorial
this is something which people
western academics have been highlighting
they have been highlighting this point
in a peer-reviewed academic journals
using
source material primary source material
to justify their
points because why
the question is why would they do that
why would the irgun who are
meant to be a paramilitary jewish
nationalistic kind of group
side with the nazis because they had the
same objectives and this gives us
something about
the way these people operate
they are completely machiavellian
meaning they are consequentialist in
their ethical reasoning
meaning that means always justify the
ends for them
and that's why we're seeing bombs being
dropped
the most sophisticated and
technologically
advanced bombs being dropped on the most
densely and defenseless
densely populated and defenseless area
in in in the whole middle east probably
which is the
the hazard script the strip
because the ends always justify the
means for them they know
that if you if you drop a bomb 30
to 40 percent chance is going to be a
child and the rest is probably going to
be some kind of civilian
you've got a two or three percent chance
of hitting who you the
the the so-called target that you want
to hit
but you don't mind killing children
because you are terrorists
and the ends always justify the means
for you are scrounge rules
weasels cowards criminals
you are diabolical your actions are
condemnable
you are megalo maniacal
you are pitfall people pip squeaks
all of you are pipsqueaks you remind me
of the verse
in the quran where ironically it speaks
about banu nadir
another treacherous tribe
at the time of prophet muhammed
in chapter 59 of the quran where it says
they don't fight you together except
from behind
in fortified in fortified places or
behind
big walls you pathetic cowardly people
you don't like face-to-face
confrontation you don't like equal
fights because you are cowardly
it doesn't take a brave person to press
a button
it doesn't take a brave person to throw
to play computer games with a
drone and kill a child it doesn't take a
brave person
to press a button from a high place
where you know that there's not going to
be a reaction
you pathetic weak weasels
fighting children for living that's what
you basically do
you fight children you kill children for
a living that's your
that is the bulk of what you do you
pathetic weasels
and you do so in the in the name of
defense defending yourself against what
defend yourself against someone your own
size
you pathetic people the second point
which i wanted to make so the first
point we've just explained that they
weren't cahoots with the hit
with the nazis and this shows you the
machiavellian nature of these
individuals
number two is that did you know
that israel funded hamas
in 1987 israel funded hamas now look at
them
the two major antagonists of
the uh of the zionist project
nazism actually you could argue nazism
helped design this project
as we've just in a sense they had the
same objectives get them out of europe
the
jewish problem they didn't mind being
serviled to the european the white man
so long as that they were they were
dominant
the zionists i'm talking about they were
dominant in another land which is not
their own
and they couldn't even fight for it
themselves the pathetic weasels the
cowards
they needed the britishers and the un
and
all these other foreign agencies america
and so on
to fight their battles for them they
don't fight those battles themselves
the only people they love killing is
civilians and children
that's that's who you've got racked up
in your record
civilians and children that's what
you're known for
terrorists the second thing is that you
funded hamas
now why would you fund hamas in 1998
this is an open secret
this is an open secret you can go ahead
and look at for example
who was an advisor he was an advisor to
the israeli government and he's also a
historian and he says quite candidly
that
yes they funded israel funded hamas
and the reason why they founded hamas is
because the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and that's always been your motto
you're pathetic people
you are you don't you don't have
principles all it is is anything that
can enhance your
uh objectives of racial superiority you
take it you funded hamas because the plo
was your enemy and this is what he says
go ahead why were they your enemies they
were your enemies
because they were the biggest throne in
your side but then you created
he says we created a monster yeah
because at that time
the narrative was against arab
nationalism now all of a sudden suddenly
it's about islamic terrorism but the
same things were happening all along
you can't you cannot blame islamic
radicalism
when the same things you were doing to
arab nationalists
secularists it's not a matter of
arab nationalism or islamism it's a
matter of resistance
and what you have done is you've tried
to pick
on the weakest part of the enemy because
you're pathetic people
you are pathetic people you are weak
cowardly people you are and you know it
you only fight people that can't fight
back
cowardly people the idea of the most
cowardly
uh jaish the most cowardly the most weak
the most pathetic
army known to humankind i don't know if
any
one who's done that they they just make
their target civilians all the time
except for the islamic terrorist groups
which you'd like to condemn but you're
practically the same in your operations
you're practically the same what's the
difference tell me the difference they
bomb civilians you bomb civilians
densely popular if this were if if you
were muslims everyone would say this
islamic radicalism no one would accept
it
but you are pathetic people and the fact
that you've been trying your hand that
narrative manipulation
is very clear because your machiavellian
efforts to try and
be in cahoots with the nazi party and
also with hamas showed me that you know
you don't really have
ethics it's all about how do we
establish authority
okay how do we establish authority as a
racial elite
and that's all and these facts
expose you as individuals who are just
trying to clutch at straws
and manipulate narratives in order to
expand your own project of racial
superiority because you
you feel maybe uh downtrodden you feel
subservient you feel
second class and you you are basically
the bully
you are basically the bully that wants
to bully now
you've been bullied for all this time
and now you want to bully yeah
now it's your turn to bully
it's a classic case and you're pathetic
and you're basically acting just like
the nazis
you're acting like them simple as that
you're doing as much as you can get away
with and we know that you're doing just
as much as you can get
if you could put these guys in gas
chambers you do if you can drop a
nuclear bomb you'd do it
but you know the international community
couldn't accept this so you're doing as
much as possible you're pathetic your
weasels your cowards and you know it
you know it assalamu alaikum is